foreign
welcome to the simply learn YouTube
channel in today's video we are going to
be talking about WordPress we're going
to show you how to use WordPress what is
WordPress what are the skills you need
to use WordPress why should you use
WordPress and in the process I'll give
you a Hands-On demo of the basic
functionality of Wordpress as usual I am
Mark campman I am your digital navigator
for this video and if you like the video
click the like button if you want to
subscribe to our Channel don't forget to
click the Subscribe button and join our
fantastic community of interactive
Learners on the simply learn YouTube
channel but before we start let me share
something else with you first simply
learn has a new program together with
meta to offer you a professional
certificate in digital marketing it's a
fan fantastic program it's the
officially official program together
with meta and it is the um if we'll go
into here into the website yeah you'll
see that it is done together with the
Purdue University with meta is the
official partner and there's also
involvement with marketing land and
search engine ancient Journal so it is a
fantastic digital marketing course and
what the real value is that you will be
qualifying for The Meta blueprint
certification and The Meta blueprint is
Facebook's famous or metas famous
certification for everything there is to
know about about Facebook so very useful
program I can highly recommend this
training to you
okay so that was a little uh sidestep
let's go back to the slides and let's go
back to the program so what we're going
to be talking about is first we're going
to talk about content Management Systems
WordPress is a Content management system
to develop a website but to understand
this how to use this it is important
that you understand the essence of a
Content management system we'll then go
into what is WordPress we'll look at the
two versions of Wordpress that are out
there we're going to look at WordPress
features and I'll give you a a brief
demo of the WordPress functionality
we're going to look at one competitor in
specific who is very trying very hard to
um to sort of bite into WordPress Market
leadership and that's a competitor
called Wix so we're going to do a short
comparison between Wix and WordPress I'm
going to then show you how to install
WordPress us and then once you've got it
installed how are you going to create
your website and then we're going to
close off today's session be having a
look at some advantages and
disadvantages right but let me give you
some facts of Wordpress first WordPress
was released in 2003 as a blogging
platform by a guy Matt mullenwick and
then his friend Mike little it was a
fork off of an older blogging platform
called B2 Cafe log and it included basic
functionalities like the ability to
create a blog post to manage commands
and upload images
yeah it grew in popularity and features
were added like plugins and custom post
pipes with lots of different updates
across the years in 2008 and to 2010 the
15th 2018 and then new features came
like a redesigned admin interface a
theme customizer and a block editor
which made it a lot easier to develop
your websites now where is WordPress
today it is the most popular CMS or
content management system in the world
over 40 percent of all websites on the
internet they use WordPress and it
continues to be one of the most the
largest community of contributors to any
CMS platform here are some other
WordPress stats WordPress Powers 40 of
the internet and is available in over
200 languages WordPress users they
publish around 70 million new blog posts
and 77 million new comments each month
and yoast SEO which is a plug-in for
search engine optimization for your
website on WordPress has been downloaded
over
372 million times as of today makes it
one of the basically makes it the most
popular WordPress plugin that you can
can use the WordPress Community consists
of over 78 million active users and over
1.5 billion monthly unique visitors they
visit the WordPress websites without
knowing that of course
wordpress.com which is a separate
version of Wordpress and I'll come back
to that in a in a minute they host over
5.5 million active websites and
automatic which is the company behind
wordpress.com is valued at over 3
billion dollars and there's over 1500
remote employees across the world yeah
so some pretty staggering numbers and it
clearly makes WordPress the market
leader when it comes to a CMS or a
Content management system for your
website now what is a Content management
system before we dive into that yeah
cmss they started in the 1990s but they
were not widely used until the early
2000s so the early CMS systems were
often proprietary expensive and very
difficult to use
PHP nuke was like the first open source
content management system in 2000 later
followed by Drupal and Drupal became in
the ocean in those days one of the
leading development platforms for your
your website WordPress released in 2003
evolved into a fully fledged CMS and
currently is the most popular CMS for
any website out there other popular
cms's include Joomla launched in 2005
and Magento very much for e-commerce
website today's there are dozens of
cms's available both proprietary and
open source now so much kind of an
introduction on CMS let's define what a
CMS actually is a CMS also known as a
Content management system is like a very
friendly website building tool it is a
software application that provides a
hosted a centralized and organized
method for managing storing and
Publishing your website or any digital
content that you want to have yeah it
helps you create manage and publish
digital content without having to be a
tag or a wizkit or learn compare
complicated coding yeah so it's all
about ease of use it's about easy
content creation and management yeah
they make it simple for non-technical
users to create edit and manage website
content without requiring specific
technical skills or programming
knowledge it also provides much faster
website developments yeah because you
can use pre-built templates you can use
plugins and that all speeds up the
website development
yeah so that reduces the need to start
from scratch to start programming your
website from scratch you just pick the
building blocks and in the process of
doing that your website sort of comes
together it's also for improved Website
Maintenance yeah so a Content management
system they provide building tools for
Website Maintenance like updating the
software security for your website
backups for your website yeah and
optimization for search engines so it is
all about making your life a lot easier
so with his CMS you can use a simple
interface and you see that later when I
show you the web the the WordPress
backend yeah so you use a simple
interface to create and organize your
content design your website and manage
the different users and their
permissions who can work on your website
it also allows you to connect with other
tools like services to make your website
go even faster or e-commerce services or
Google services so they are designed to
be flexible they are designed to be
extensible yeah and one of the ways to
achieve this is by connecting the
various types of tools to your content
management system and by connecting to
databases cmss can store all data and
your content in a very effective way
now one of the big advantages of content
Management Systems is their open
architecture yeah so you can connect
what we call third-party apis to enhance
the functionality of your CMS
yep so you can add tools like Google
analytics or
um
Salesforce HubSpot all tools through the
API you can connect you can connect
social media integration e-commerce
capability
Etc so it's a very open platform and
that makes them so interesting and then
one of the biggest assets of CNS cms's
and that's where WordPress is so
incredibly flexible you can have plugins
and extensions they are available which
can be installed to add features like
SEO contact forms image galleries
e-commerce you name it and you'll see in
WordPress there are thousands and
thousands of plugins for free or that
you pay for that gives you that added
functionality in in WordPress so in
general any website that needs to manage
and publish content on a regular basis
can benefit from a CMS
yeah because it can help you with
content organization it helps you with
Version Control with workflow management
user management and many other tasks
that are essential for creating and
managing your website
so there are many types of websites that
can benefit from a CMS so take for
instance a standard block yes so with a
CMS for a Blog website it's easy to
create and publish your blog posts as
well as managing the comments and other
user generated content
yeah you have news websites
they sort of are a big aggregator of all
the news out there so for them it's easy
to create and manage blog posts as well
as they can help with the organization
and the management of the content
because they've got a huge amount of
news articles on their website and by
setting tags and by setting categories
you can give people easy access to that
content
e-commerce websites they can manage
product listings yep so that's what the
cables can do for you managing product
listings manage pricing manage inventory
as well as tools to manage the orders
and the customer data
and corporate websites they can use a
CMS as well they can benefit from it so
it can include product and service
information news and events career
opportunities so basically every website
every type of website can benefit from
um from a CMS system
so as I said WordPress is one of the
leading CMS systems out there
so let's dive a bit deeper into
WordPress now bear in mind there are two
versions of Wordpress
there is wordpress.com
and there is wordpress.org
yeah wordpress.com is a hosted service
provider yeah that provides a simplified
version of the WordPress software
so you don't have to worry about hosting
it wordpress.com will host it for you
the only thing you do is to create an
account select a theme put in your
content press publish and your website
is live but it offers a limited set of
features themes and plugins so users
have limited control over the technical
aspects of their website but it is
really good for those people who want to
create a website quickly without the
hassle of any technical
complications or technical knowledge it
is literally go to wordpress.com create
an account select a theme add your
content press publish and your website
is live you don't need any longer
knowledge for that the basic version is
free of wordpress.com but as soon as
you're going to add additional
functionality like your own URL or
specific search engine optimization
features then you're going to pay a
premium fee but they're still not that
expensive
wordpress.org
is a CMS platform it's an open source
software that can be downloaded and
installed on your own web hosting server
and usually you go to a server a web
hosting server provider like GoDaddy or
Amazon or wherever you and you install
WordPress you basically hire a little
space on their server
yep and then you install WordPress and
then you have to develop your website
within that CMS so it's a self-hosted
solution and it gives you complete
control over the website's design the
website's functionality and the
customization options through
wordpress.org you have access to
thousands of themes thousands of plugins
and you can even modify the code of your
website if you would like that but you
are responsible for installing and
maintaining the WordPress software as
well as managing other things like
backup security hosting
Etc but it gives you flexibility it
gives you customization and if you're
comfortable with that if you have your
basic technical skills and you're
comfortable with managing your own
hosting and server configurations then
WordPress is definitely the place for
you wordpress.org right so when we're
going to talk about WordPress going
forward in this presentation I'm going
to be talking about
wordpress.org yeah so keep that in mind
I'm not talking about wordpress.com but
wordpress.org I'm going to talk to you
about how to set up your own WordPress
on your own hosted server provider as it
were
okay and we're going to go through that
process so wordpress.org again is free
software for creating your website and
your blog so it's a self-hosted solution
which means you need to find a web
hosting company and you need to install
it on their servers against you have
complete control over your design your
functionality your customization and you
can choose from thousands of themes and
plugins but again you are responsible
for the hosting and the security right
so keep that in mind so let's have a
look at basic features of Wordpress
there are three basic features it's the
themes the plugins
and the widgets yeah so the themes they
control the appearance of the website
plugins add new features and
functionality and widgets display extra
content or functionality in specific
areas on the website
yes so they are used to customize the
appearance and the functionality of your
website so die let's dive a little bit
deeper themes they are pre-designed
templates that change the look and the
layout of your WordPress website
yeah they control the overall design the
color scheme the fonts that are being
used and style of the website and there
are literally thousands tens of
thousands themes available on the
website you can select them through
WordPress you can also go to website and
I'll show you later theme forest for
instance where you can just look at
other themes and you can just either
there sometimes are for free others
their premium so you just click on the
theme and you click install and it will
activate on your WordPress website
plugins are add-ons that extend the
functionality of a WordPress website so
they can be used used for features like
SEO contact forms social media sharing
buttons e-commerce functionality they're
very useful and there are estimate we
saw with the the themes there are
thousands and thousands of free and
premium plugins available in the
WordPress directory you can also use
your own theme which you have or your
own plugins but you have to be careful
with your plugins
because WordPress updates regularly to a
new version
yeah but you need to make sure that your
plugins are compliant with the new
updates so from from WordPress and
sometimes if your plugin provider is not
updating the plugin in line with the
WordPress updates then your plugin may
stop working and that may dysfunction
your your website widgets are small
modules that can be added to a sidebar
of a website or a header or a footer so
it gives you extra functionality or
extra content in that particular section
so you can have a search bar recent post
categories text social media icons or as
ads that you can have most themes bear
in mind they come pre-built widgets
included and users can also create your
own custom widgets
so let's look at three examples of
popular websites built on WordPress so
you get a bit of an idea yes so the
first website
that people may be surprised throughout
is the Walt Disney Company
yeah so this is a you see a huge company
a global Corporation they use a
WordPress CMS to to sort of build their
entire website yeah so it's all that's
the beauty about content web about
WordPress it's basically a a container
for the huge amount of content that you
have on your website
yeah and you see that here in the new
section that is where all their articles
are featured like blog post basically
yeah and you can access them through the
um the the website
okay so that is the Walt Disney Company
so it's a very user-friendly design very
easy navigation and it's great way to
find all the information about the
company TechCrunch is another one it's a
leading technology website that covers
the latest in Tech news for star and and
startups it's built on WordPress and it
features a responsive design that looks
great on both the desktop and the mobile
yeah so it includes a mix of Articles
videos podcasts and it allows users to
easily Browse by topic or search for
specific articles now what is a
responsive design a responsive design is
very important a responsive design means
that your website will automatically
resize to the device that the user is
using
yes so is basically it's a mobile
version a mobile-friendly version of
your website and when you pick a design
you always need to make sure that the
design is responsive and the best way to
test is if you make the website smaller
that it will automatically resize and
you can see that here yeah resize
ultimately to the mobile formats so the
third example was Star Wars It's the
official Star Wars blog it's a fan site
that cover all things related to Star
Wars from movies TV shows to books and
comment comics
it's built on WordPress and it features
a design that reflects the Star Wars
Universe complete with their custom
fonts and background it includes News
interviews fan content as well as a
forum where users can discuss here in
the community where users can discuss
their favorite Star Wars topics yeah so
that's an example of three WordPress
websites yep so
that's uh that's it yeah so let's have a
look at the back end system of Wordpress
to get an idea what sits behind this
website so if I go to my own website and
that is react for Russia yeah that is a
um a kind of a how should I have in in
Marrakesh in Morocco that I rent out
that people can it's on Airbnb but
um besides that this website is built on
WordPress now a very easy way to find
out if a website is built on WordPress
is basically after the URL you just type
WP hyphen admin yeah that is what you
need to access
the backend it will ask you for a user
ID and a password
if the website is the the browser comes
back with URL does not exist then you
know that this website has not been
built on WordPress
okay so let's wait till we get the
access
oh I've already logged in yeah so that's
why we don't see uh the login screen
um but that's okay yeah you'll get first
a login screen you sign in and then you
get to your uh your dashboard so here
you see your WordPress the dashboard you
see the theme that I used yep and then
here is some updates that are required
at a glance how many posts how many
pages I can add a quick article
Etc but here you see on the left you see
the menu
yes so you see basically the most
important ones are your blog posts
are your website pages
yeah so WordPress works with pages and
posts pages are static Pages like your
home page
yeah posts are blog posts
okay so that's the basically the essence
of the structure of Wordpress then here
you see your themes
and then here you see your plugins
yep and then you have tools you have
your setting I've set up SEO on the site
I've set up Google analytics yes if I go
to my pages
and look at all pages
then here you get a list of all the
pages that you have active on your
website
okay so go to posts and you get a list
of all the posts that you have on your
website
the blog posts if you want to add a new
post you just click here add new if you
want to add a new page you can also
hover over the pages and then click add
new
you can add different things like
portfolio
or testimonials or products or Services
yeah and here is your media library this
is where you have all the photos and
videos that you have that you use on
your website
okay and here you have your theme
options so I selected a specific theme
and then here you see all the things
that you can change on your theme
so nothing to program yeah you can just
go through all these items and select
the um the specific options for that
section so you have the side layout the
header style
Etc
yes so that's the theme options
so these are all the options that you
can specify
and then here you have your appearance
so here you see the themes and you also
see the widgets and you can also specify
the menus
so when you start your website the first
thing WordPress will ask you go to the
themes
and then it will come default with two
or three themes
but you can
search for themes as well so you see
there are virtue there are probably a
handful of themes that I've got here
yeah but I got these are sort of
available I can also search for new
themes
okay so I can search here in WordPress I
can also search on outside WordPress in
a theme forest for instance and then
bring in the the theme into WordPress
okay so those are the themes here are
your widgets
you see a list of widgets that you have
available
yeah so here you see the widgets that
I've installed and where they are in the
sidebar the home Widget the footer
column yeah we have four footer columns
and here is the available widgets that I
can add
okay and then very important here is
your page with plugins I can search you
my installed plugins or can or I can add
new plugins so go to the install plugins
and then you see what plugins are you
have installed
yep and then you can add new plugins as
well
so that is a bit a very high level
overview of the WordPress functionality
I just want to leave it at this
um
it's important to understand yeah if we
go back to this the features if you want
to sort of summarize them
the one big benefit of Wordpress in the
features it is a very user-friendly
interface
it's a very intuitive interface yeah and
it makes it easy for users to create and
manage content on the website
the second big Advantage is the wide
range of customizable themes and
templates that you can select from that
is that's where WordPress is
second to num the availability of the
themes now there is a bit of a drawback
here I just want you to be aware of that
yeah if you are a WordPress expert if
you know WordPress quite well you will
see that a lot of the themes they have
kind of the same structure yes so I can
kind of recognize if a website is built
on WordPress or not yeah because the
themes are rarely
um fairly sort of similar but they
differ by the look and feel of them so
keep that in mind
yet always very important make sure that
the website is adaptive yeah it's
responsive and that is another big
advantage of Wordpress that it has a
responsive and a mobile friendly design
another big advantage and the features
of plugin is their extensive of their
extensive plugin and widget architecture
yeah and that gives you a tremendous
library of functionality that you can
use on your on your website
because of these plugins you can also
very easily optimize your website for
SEO so WordPress has built-in features
for that but one of the best SEO plugins
is yoast SEO
where you can add meta tags site Maps
permalinks descriptions page titles
Etc
and then finally the features in
WordPress they really stand out when it
comes to supporting multi-languages
yes there was multiple languages making
it easy to create and manage websites
for international companies
and then to close very good features are
around the e-commerce with plug games
like woocommerce WordPress can power any
e-commerce website and can handle
transactions Inventory management and
and more
besides that the core engine of
Wordpress is its blogging platform
yes so it's still one of the best
blogging platforms but it is now also of
course has the capabilities to build
your entire website around it but the
blogging capabilities they include
posting post scheduling commenting and
social media sharing
WordPress also offers a fantastic
library for media management yeah so
making it easy to upload store manage
all types of media files like images
audio video PDFs and what have you
and to close the feature list off there
is a very strong Community around
WordPress very large very active for
Developers for designers and users they
contribute to the ongoing development of
Wordpress they provide support they
create themes and plugins to extend the
functionality and if you have a problem
I'm sure you can find an answer in the
WordPress Community because other people
will have experienced those problems as
well
okay now let's compare WordPress with
the comp competition
and I'm going back now to wordpress.com
and wordpress.org
yeah I remember wordpress.com was the
basic
um where WordPress would take care of
the hosting
yeah so you just open an account and
publish your site so competitors with
wordpress.com are Wix webflow
Squarespace bubble Soho sites
Square online which was formerly Weebly
I really like Weebly by the way and odoo
website builder if you look at
competitors for website wordpress.org we
look at HubSpot CMS Hub progress
sitefinity Drupal Joomla kentico
contentful and if you look at e-commerce
competitors we look at Shopify ionos
Squarespace volusion and big Commerce
now one of the big competitors although
they are in the hosted
um
section yeah they are in the
wordpress.com section but they are
trying to eat in WordPress market share
in the
um the the wordpress.org section is wix
yes so although Wix provides hosting as
part of its own platform
WordPress yeah we're talking about a
comparison of Wix with wordpress.org
requires users to pay for the hosting so
keep that in mind
so Wix has been around for quite a few
years
and it was initially you just go to Wix
yeah you like wordpress.com you create
an account and you select a theme you
add your content click publish and your
website is live
where Wix stood out where they were
truly unique was on the quality of their
designs of their themes
yeah they were clearly a level higher
better quality than the WordPress themes
now in the early days one of the reasons
why Wix was so so powerful and so so
popular was because of the quality of
its themes
yeah and that that's where it really
stood out from WordPress now one of the
reasons why these themes stood out was
that they were developed only Jaffa
yep and with Java you have a lot more
flexibility on creating really nice kind
of themes but the problem with Java was
that Google couldn't index pages that
were built with Java because it was very
proprietary coding the text was kind of
buried in the code
so
in the early days Wix had a very poor
reputation when it came to search engine
optimization
over the years that has changed Wix is
now no longer using Java because Java is
is gone yeah but still there is this
sort of negative connotation with Wix is
not good for search engine optimization
but those are
um yeah as you know these things they
Linger on
so wix
because it is hosted
yeah so Wix has a more limited set of
templates and Designs available
because they are coming from Wix as it
were
yeah where WordPress is highly
customizable with thousands of plugins
and themes available
yeah so you've got to understand that so
Wix is kind of closed where WordPress is
open
now there is another element here which
is kind of a negative on WordPress
because WordPress is so open
with plugins and themes coming from so
many different sources it is also
slightly more vulnerable for spam and
for
um
attacks on your website
yeah where Works where Wix is more
protected now let's look at those
themes so if I go to uh
uh Wix so here you see Wix create a
website that means business
still very good themes yep so very easy
to start very friendly to set up I'm not
going to log in or get started I'm just
going to show you the if I go to the
creation and I'm going to the website
templates
yeah 800 plus designer made templates
and here you see a selection of the
different templates that you can have a
look at
yes so you can uh just click on the
template you can edit that means you can
turn it into your website or you can
view the template how it would look like
so let's look here on view and then see
a live version of what the website would
look like
SEC they look really good
usually there's a starting point click
State onto editing site so you see how
easy it is to make
if I go to Wordpress themes I showed you
how to find the themes on WordPress
yeah I can also go to a site like theme
forests
yep and then here you have a huge
library of 50
000 WordPress plugins
yeah at various prices you can get them
for free you can get them for premium
you just look at the the theme so take
for instance
um
total WordPress
responsive yes so here you see look at
the live preview
and then here you can see the different
demos that they have yeah so you click
here on the demo and then you see how
the demo would look like
and then you can buy the demo and then
install it on your
on your WordPress installation
okay so those are the themes
that are very important and that is
where
um Wix has a more limited set but very
creative WordPress highly customable
with thousands of plugins and thousands
of themes
so Wix is known for its ease of use
yeah so anybody can easily start a
website on Wix but remember you have
limited control over the technical
aspects of your website because it is
managed by wix
where WordPress
wordpress.org you have complete control
so although you need more technical
skills yeah it gives you complete
control over the design adding
functionality even coding the website if
you want to
so keep that in mind
as we said earlier as well Wix has more
limited set of SEO options
historically remember with the Java
format that they had yeah the you may
need to upgrade your plan on Wix to get
more SEO features where on WordPress
you have the most fantastic SEO plugins
like yoast SEO all-in-one SEO which
gives full SEO
functionality on your website and we all
know how important SEO is
right now let's look at how we're going
to install WordPress
yes so there's two options
you can
do it through a hosting provider
yeah there are two options
there are two options you can be guided
by your hosting provider
or you can do it all yourself
so let me show you first how to do it
through your hosting provider
so here is my hosting provider which is
GoDaddy
yeah on GoDaddy I have multiple products
and one of my products is hosting
okay and I'll show you later the details
around that but when you go to your
hosting section in your service provider
yeah then here you have a list of the
websites that you are having installed
on the provider's server
if you want to add a new website which
is Guided by the hosting provider the
only thing you have to do is to go to
your admin panel
and in your admin panel you have all the
apps that you have access to
that could be email it could be file
manager it could be the images but
there's also apps that you can install
like WordPress or Magento or Joomla
so the only thing you need to do if you
want to install WordPress on your
hosting providers server you just click
here on WordPress
that will then take you into a dialogue
yep and then you will just fill in the
details the name of your website the
user ID password yep and then it will
install it for you on your
um on your server so that's one way of
installing it
the second way of installing is do it
yourself
yeah and that's a bit more complicated
but these are the steps you will have to
go through first of all you need to
decide on what hosting provider you're
going to use that could be GoDaddy
Bluehost HostGator and what have you
then you go and actually download the
latest version of Wordpress from the
official WordPress website
then what you do you're going to upload
WordPress on your server that you have
with the server provider yep so you can
use an FTP client like filezilla or as I
showed you just now through your web
hosting control panel when word when go
dead Go Daddy does it for you yeah like
when your hosting provider does it for
you they create your SQL database if you
do it yourself you will have to create
your own mySQL database and your hosting
provider has an app for that
then you run the WordPress installation
script it will then create the WordPress
file and create a database and then you
can configure WordPress yeah so you log
into your admin area you choose the
theme add to plugins create the pages
and you launch your site
that is how easy it is when you want to
do it yourself okay now back to the
hosting provider for a sec yeah it's
important that you understand if I go to
GoDaddy
yeah then here you see the different
type of products that you have
so these are the products that I use I
have a section on domains so I have
bought domains
that they manage for me
yep so here are my domains I have web
hosting
yeah so that is where I buy my slice of
their web server
yeah always make sure it has a cpanel
which is an admin the admin section
okay then very important make sure that
you buy web hosting and that you add SSL
certificates you may have heard of SSL
certificates they are the S between
behind HTTP yeah so https which is
basically a required security feature
that Google wants to see on your website
and then Additionally you can buy
website security
which is important and backups and
there's many other products but these
are the core products that you need from
your hosting provider okay so we are all
set up we have WordPress ready let's now
look at again at the website creation
so once you've chosen your hosting
provider and we talked about it you're
then going to install WordPress either
do it yourself or through your hosting
provider and then the first thing you're
going to do is choose a theme and I've
shown you the library of themes
yeah so there are free themes there are
bait themes that you can choose from and
you can also install custom themes
directly from a third-party developer
website and then you're going to
customize your theme what I like about
many of the themes they come with demos
and you can actually download the demo
so you see the full website completely
ready completely installed with the demo
and the only thing you have to do is to
change the content of the demo with your
own content
then you're going to add your logo
Etc you're going to add your own blog
post you're going to change your pages
upload to texting your pages yep and
then you're going to add plugins like
SEO like social media sharing and
whatever you like forms and then you're
going to publish your website
yes so you can then publish it for the
world to see and share it on social
media and start promoting your website
once your website is ready what you
basically do you link your website to
your url
yep and that's the the hosting provider
can take it can can do that all for you
one important aspect on the hosting
provider make sure that you check the
surface options from your hosting
provider if you have a technical problem
how good are they at responding and the
minimum you should look for is that they
have a chat capability
because there's nothing worse than
having to wait for a call when you call
them wait for half an hour or an hour on
the phone before you get an answer I
always prefer to do that through chat
right so what are the advantages and the
disadvantages of Wordpress
the big approach on WordPress are open
source customization large community
very SEO friendly and content management
yeah so it's the easiest CMS out there
and because it's open there are
literally tons of options to customize
it
if you have problems there is a huge
WordPress community that can help you
find the answers
if you want to do your SEO for your
website yeah WordPress has fantastic
plugins like yoast SEO all in one SEO to
actually
make the SEO as easy and smooth as
possible for your website so the large
community is really helpful in WordPress
if you have any problems with your with
your website and with your WordPress
installation and of course the content
management is very important as you can
see as you saw on the demo is you can
really access the blog posts the pages
the media in a very friendly way so
there's lots of benefits in using
WordPress but there are some negatives
as well
yeah and I think a big negative is its
open source positive yeah because it's
open source the security is slightly
more at risk as it were yes so you're
more prone to attacks and to spam than
um on on closed platforms yep and as
well of course you do need some
technical skills yeah maintenance is an
issue as well yeah so and I mentioned
that earlier if you have an update on
the WordPress
um sort of the WordPress sort of a CMS
then your plugins need to be upgraded as
well and some plug-in providers they're
later with upgrading and it may happen
that plugins stop working after a
WordPress CMS upgrade so you need to be
very alert to those things and one final
issue that may come up with WordPress is
that they tend to be slightly slower in
in performance which basically means it
takes longer to load a page so you need
to be aware of that you need to track
that you need to measure that and you
can get tools in WordPress as a plugin
that can help you with improving the
speed of your website
so that's a wrap folks that's all there
is as an introduction to Wordpress I
hope you found this useful there's more
to come in the future on this but for
now this is as far as we want to take
this so if you like the video don't
forget to click the like button or
subscribe to our Channel by clicking the
Subscribe button and join our fantastic
simply learn online learning community
that's it and I'll see you next week at
the next video that we're going to
publish for you take care for now
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign